it was a very physical performance very
physically uh challenging morbius is
finally out after a whopping six delays
so let's take a look at what was up
behind the scenes all this time
hopefully jared leto managed to not gift
his co-star a live rat or bat in a box
number one everybody's doing prosthetics
well i've just gotta be special then
most people prefer to use practical
effects like prosthetics originally that
was going to be the case for morbius but
jared leto had other ideas he pushed
incredibly hard to have the vampire all
done through motion capture so that his
acting ability wasn't limited to the
motions of the prosthetics the motion
capture tech they used was the same that
was used for thanos visual effects
supervisor matthew e butler said there's
limitless potential using some of these
new technologies so it's interesting to
be part of that and to push the envelope
they had leto done up in an array of
dots with a camera mounted onto a helmet
on his head to capture the subtleties in
the actor's expressions the software can
translate leto's performance into the
performance of a creature that is
completely different since it was all
done using cgi nobody had actually seen
the face of morbius until the very end
so we had to use our imaginations i had
to be quite patient letto felt he'd
taken a huge leap of faith relying on
the cgi department
number two somebody give morbius a
snickers jared leto is attracted to
transformative characters because he
finds they are challenging to pull off
it's like kind of tailored for me
getting in shape for the role was very
physically demanding it was very very
demanding i mean i was just shattered at
the end of every day pledo wasn't all
that affected having to lose all that
weight to portray the sickly form of dr
morbius though i don't actually get
hangry because i do a lot of fasting he
went from zero to anti-hero pretty quick
too he likes that it's this big marvel
movie with action and adventure but it
also walks on the darker side of the
universe i i liked as well that there's
a jekyll and hyde at times it is quite
scary which makes it very different he
got to play the sick and frail dr
morbius and the healthy and jacked form
and then the monstrous version
number three we wouldn't want to share
the screen with jared leto knowing
behind the scenes he's trying to get
that jump scare not a lot can scare
letto but he sure likes to scare others
i'm definitely known to hide around the
door and
don't we know it from his time on set as
the joker live rats dead pigs sent to
set by the vegan himself sounds like he
tailors his pranks to the movies so who
knows what kind of vampire stuff he was
up to during morbius
number four inspiration can come from
anywhere when it came to echolocation
the team was hoping to go in a different
direction than anyone's ever taken there
tends to be a trend among media that
it's portrayed as a dark room with a
burst of light going through it well for
morbius they got their inspiration from
anime and not just any anime they got it
from pokemon of all places how wild is
that pokemon gotta catch em all and
morbius is number 472 in the pokedex
look it up if you don't believe us
number five do you think the people
filming on their cell phones broke
non-disclosure agreements manchester was
made up to look like new york and we
quite appreciate that barry aird is
getting makeup applied to the top of his
head hi sorry we think we're lost we
were looking for where morbius was
filming not doctor who and while you
peruse the footage now seems like a good
time to mention that morbius is directed
by daniel espinoza and written by matt
sezama and burke sharpless action now
imagine if you were stuck in new york
traffic and you could just yell action
and all the traffic would suddenly get
moving
what a dream
number six sometimes you can bring
something to a character and sometimes a
character brings something to you
martine definitely taught adria a lot
about herself as a person
she she definitely taught me a lot she
taught me to sort of speak my mind she's
unsure if the people around her like it
now but she really likes it and that's
all that matters there's parts about her
that i love and there's parts about her
that i definitely had to work on and
sort of create matt smith finds the most
joyous experience of being an actor is
that you get to sort of recalibrate and
rewire yourself and focus and think in
an entirely different way number seven
leto is an interesting actor yep
interesting that's a good way to
describe him he's also a very dedicated
actor he doesn't break character while
he's on the set but director daniel
espinoza is the first to admit that leto
isn't the only one in hollywood to do
this denzel washington also doesn't
break character while he's shooting
that's an odd thing to say in an
interview no it almost sounds like he's
not the biggest fan of leto i was in a
jared sandwich and it was wonderful matt
smith on the other hand is of course
talking about both jared leto and jared
harris both are fabulous actors with
very different processes so says matt
number eight to be big or not to be big
that's a goofy question go big or go
home matt smith feels that the story of
morbius is like shakespeare because you
can make bold choices because the
universe in itself is quite big in many
ways you can be a bit bigger as matt put
it so you can be quite bold with the
brush strokes that you throw at the
canvas as it were onto the less boring
analogy number nine ah somebody hand
morbius a towel the epic morbius costume
was abandoned at least for now after
talking about it they decided it just
wasn't going to happen for a first film
leto does think that there are some
pretty great examples in the early
comics and ideas of where they could go
in the future if they suited up that
that could be a lot of fun actually he
likes a lot of those costume elements
number 10 research for a marvel film
would be fun you just get to kick back
and read comics how great is that so the
artwork for me was a great source of
inspiration leto looked at everything he
finds that's what's great about the
characters that there's so much material
to dive into and it's such a rich world
he read everything he could i talked to
doctors and scientists and
you know did the research and letto
really enjoys that part of the process
he loves to dive in and do that
preparation
number eleven it's always good to have a
friend on the inside matt smith's doctor
who co-star karen gillen of course
played a large role in the mcu nebula
and she is obsessed with her role
despite all the time that goes into
prosthetics well when matt smith was
given the offer he phoned guillen to ask
what her experience was like and she
said go for it
number 12 the future is uncertain or
leto is lying to us if audiences enjoy
the character into the film leto is more
than happy to come back he's thrilled
about the potential of the sinister six
getting together but morbius is a
spin-off of spider-man so i think
morbius spider-man that that's a meeting
that has to happen but the questions are
there which spider-man what universe is
morbius existing in nobody really
thought he would be brought to the
cinema for a while so there's a lot on
the table right now what excited me the
most about playing morbius was the fact
that he has never been on screen before
um yeah fun times
morbius looks spooky but vampires are a
pretty hard sell nowadays i'm glad that
we we ended up in that place they really
missed their prime with this one when it
should have premiered in the early 2010s
either way better late than never do you
think jared leto was good casting for
morbius and uh he's a good
person um and and that is that's
interesting to play that after his time
playing the joker it's a bit surprising
he's taken up a marvel role at all but
he thinks their rivalry encourages great
art and also gets him awesome jobs so
what does he care let us know your
thoughts in the comments and thanks for
hanging out with us here at the things